as more and more foreign nationals pour
across
the southern border of the united states
illegally the
biden administration has to figure out
what to do with the children who are
coming
into the united states and so to deal
with this situation as the washington
post
tells us yesterday the first migrant
facility for
children opens under biden
the first migrant facility that sounds
sort of nice doesn't have a nice
facility
is it sort of like the four seasons is
it
uh oh no it's a bunch of cages it's the
cages
that joe biden said was a human rights
abuse uh those are now being reopened
under joe biden but it's perfectly fine
they're they're it's a biden box
it's the it's a special metallic hotel
just don't call it a cage i'm michael
knowles that's the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from tim the enchanter
who says
let me get let me get this straight we
must respect the
dignity of boys who want to win by
pretending to be girls
but the dignity of of the girls against
whom they compete is not part of the
equation
that's right that's right because the
the reason that we need to let boys into
the girls room and let boys beat women
at
track meets and things like that is in
the name of
inclusion and so if you are
being inclusive if you are being
tolerant that means you got to bring
everybody in
and it also means that you can't be
inclusive of people who are not
inclusive it means you can't be tolerant
of people who are intolerant and those
poor little girls who just want to win
their college scholarships they are
being
very exclusive and intolerant so
we can't care about what they think
we've got to let the boys beat them
at the high school sports you know when
i think about the difference between men
and women i think about their different
health needs
and for a lot of guys you got to check
out kim's
for hims.com is all about men's wellness
do you need help with ed
hair loss or have a cold interested in
mental health or covet 19
home tests hems is here for you through
hymns
you can get the prescription medication
that treats ed real science real
solutions to ed
you get the same active ingredient as
that expensive little pill
but without the expensive price tag this
could cost
hundreds of dollars if you had to go
through a doctor or pharmacy
hymns makes it simple and affordable no
embarrassing conversations
no expensive appointments just answer a
few questions online about your medical
history
and a provider will confidentially
review i know a lot of guys don't want
to talk about
this sort of thing but if you are
encountering this issue
which is very widespread there's a
simple solution don't
hold yourself off from that there is now
a very simple way to do that
try hims today by starting out with a
free online visit go to for hims.com
michael for your free visit that is for
hims.com michael f-o-r-h-i-m-s dot com
slash michael prescription products are
subject to medical provider approval and
require an online consultation with a
medical provider who will determine if a
prescription is appropriate
see website for full details and safety
information remember that is for
hims.com
michael go check out hymns today
migrant facility dozens of migrant teens
boarded vans monday for the trip down a
dusty road
to a former man camp for oil field
workers here the first
migrant child facility opened
under the biden administration the
facility is being reactivated
to hold up to 700 children ages 13
through 17. okay this interest i don't
know much about this facility
then a few paragraphs down but
immigration lawyers and advocates
question why the biden administration
would choose to reopen a trump-era
facility
that was the source of protests and
controversy oh it's the cages
it's the cages right but when it was
donald trump opening these facilities
and using these facilities
it was truly people were calling it a
crime against humanity
the trump administration said what are
we going to do with the kids we don't
know where else to put them you're not
going to put them in jail you're not
going to put this a lot of them are
unaccompanied
where you've got to put them in a
facility you can't just let them go free
into the country
now biden does it perfectly fine nothing
to see here
democracy dies in darkness jensaki our
favorite current white house press
secretary was just asked about this
didn't have a great answer why is the
binding administration reopening
a temporary facility for migrant
children in
texas well first
the policy of this administration as you
all know but just for others is
not to expel unaccompanied children who
arrive at the border
and the process how it works is that
customs and border control
can continue to transfer unaccompanied
children to the hhs office of refugee
resettlement that can take
a couple of days i just want to give
this context so people need to
understand the process
but because of covid19 protocols uh
the like social distancing requirements
the capacity to existing office of
refugee resettlement shelters has been
significantly reduced
because of course you can't have a child
in every bed
there needs to be spacing and we abide
by those spacing to protect
the kids who are living in those
facilities for a short period of time
and to ensure the health and safety of
these kids hhs took steps to
open an emergency facility to add
capacity where these children can be
provided the care they need while they
are safely before they are safely placed
with families
and sponsors so it's a temporary
reopening during covet 19
our intention is very much to close it
okay i don't have any more time
to keep listening to this long-winded
answer does
jen sake ever intend to address the
question the question is
why are you putting kids in cages after
you campaigned
against putting kids in cages and she
said well uh
because uh it's temporary and um because
the coronavirus and you know the man i'm
gonna get i'm gonna get to it
uh and the migrants and you know
and and it's and did i mention kovid but
no i'm going to get to your question so
peter ducey to his credit
he uh says lady this ain't an answer
come on you said
you said these were human rights abuses
how can you now with a straight face
put kids right back in the exact same
facilities that you called cages
it's the same facility that was open for
a month in the trump administration
summer 2019
that is when joe biden said under trump
there have been horrifying scenes at the
border of kids being
kept in cages and kamala harris said uh
basically babies and cages
is a human rights abuse being committed
by the united states government so how
is this any different than that we very
much feel that way
uh and these are facilities let me be
clear here one
there's a pandemic going on i'm sure
you're not suggesting that we have
children right next to each other uh in
ways that are not coveted safe
i i look okay i grant i grant
that it is a human rights abuse what
we're doing right now yeah kamal harris
is totally right we very
oh yeah we totally agree with kamala
harris yeah what we're doing
is a violation of human rights because
we're putting
babies in cages but what's the
alternative
expose them to a virus that they're
statistically
it's basically impossible for them to
have any consequences from
hold on you're telling me you're telling
me you would rather expose children
to a cough than put babies in cages
are you a monster come on we have to
make hard choices it's very clear
that the there is a virus going on
statistically
uh no children have trouble with this
virus
uh but that means that we've got to put
the kids in the cages i don't think so
brings us back to a point that president
trump made during the campaign this is
another one going to be memory hold this
is another one put a little
bookmark before they take this one off
of youtube
donald trump it was one of the most
memorable lines of an otherwise
sort of awful debate when joe biden was
rambling on about the stupid
concept that you're putting kids in
cages joe biden
attacks trump for it donald trump says
who built the cages joe
they got separated from their parents
and it makes us a laughing stock and
violates every notion of who we are as a
nation
let me ask you a friend they did it we
changed the policy you're responsible
we did not they built the cages they who
built the cages
let's talk about who built the cages
let's talk about what we're talking
about
who built the cages joe you know we were
told that joe biden was going to be a
return to normalcy and i guess
it is because not only is joe biden
acting like an utter hypocrite here
right he campaigns against kids in cages
which is not exactly
what it is right it's i actually sort of
agree with the washington post today
it is a temporary facility to put
migrant children but
it was also a temporary facility to put
migrant children
when trump did it but what's good for
the goose is good for the gander so not
only is biden hypocritical now
but it was obama and biden who first
started this policy
as donald trump pointed out very well
aoc
even is siding with the republicans here
against the protestations of gensake joe
biden and kamala harris she says
this is not okay never has been okay
never will be okay
no matter the administration or party so
at least
she's coming out she sort of has to come
out right if she doesn't come out and
say what the biden administration is
doing is wrong
then she's just a complete fraud now
she's not exactly going too hard here
what is it one tweet
about a washington post article she's
not actually going to hold members of
her party to any account so i think she
is still sort of a fraud but
even she has to come out and say man
biden can't you make this a little
easier for us to defend you
because your policy is the exact same
thing
as donald trump's by the way that is not
the only area
where democrats are doing exactly the
same thing that they're accusing
republicans of there is a clip that was
just
unearthed from david letterman's old
late show
where joe biden many many years ago when
he could still form a coherent english
sentence
went on the show and described i kid you
not
he described being arrested
for breaking into the capitol would you
call it
uh i don't know an insurrection i don't
know
but but joe biden claims to have been
arrested for the exact same thing
that the crazy guy with the face paint
and the horns was arrested for on
january 6th
what was that like walking into the
great senate chamber
at 29 years old you know i walked in
when i was 21
and i got arrested i was it was a
saturday i was down
visiting some friends at georgetown
university and uh
i came up on a saturday morning because
i was fascinated with the senate and
they had a saturday session i walked up
those days
no guards stopping everywhere and i and
they just got out of session i walked in
the back
all of a sudden i found myself in the
chamber and i was stunned i walked up
sat down the presiding officer's seat
guy grabbed me by the shoulder
said you're under arrest what a classic
joe biden story
did that actually happen probably not
like most joe biden stories he is
probably the most notorious liar in
american politics that's why he had to
drop out of the 1988 presidential
election
but this is an inconvenient probable lie
for joe biden because
he's claiming to do exactly what we are
now told was
the worst insurrection in american
history and the
most calamitous thing that's ever
happened in our country joe biden saying
yeah i did that when i was 21. yeah i
got arrested for it too
but now i'm old smiling joe now i'm a
senator
even you know aoc is not the only member
of her party
who is breaking with rank on this issue
of the migrant children and joe biden
being a total hypocrite
naomi wolfe one of the most famous
feminists in the entire country
just recently went on tucker carlson's
show
also to break with her fellow travelers
not on the issue of
the lockdown or not on the issue rather
of the migrant facilities but on the
issue of these lockdowns this much
much broader issue going on around the
country and i think you're going to see
this
more and more you're going to see people
who other
call them feminists maybe they're
members of some other activist group on
the left
democrats who say hold on we can't
continue to do this forever we've been
slowing the spread for a very long time
now
now is are these sort of breakaways
enough
to take away joe biden's power i don't
think so i think it's going to be
all sort of soft pushback the sort of
thing where aoc sends a tweet
about a washington post article that she
doesn't like
but you you will start to see that build
and that could have an effect maybe
in the 2022 election maybe even in the
2024 election because things
are going to continue to get more and
more tense and you know when things are
really tense
uh one investment that i would like to
make is in physical gold i
like investing in precious metals the
price of gold has been skyrocketing
lately now there is a new way to buy
gold
through a company called acre one of the
issues with
investing in physical gold is that gold
is expensive right so you know unless
you have zillions of dollars lying
around the couch
a lot of people feel that they can't
invest in physical gold well acre
has figured out this ingenious way to do
it they will let you subscribe to gold
bars for as little as 30 dollars a month
you pay each month
once your gold stash reaches the price
of their gold bars they will discreetly
ship acre gold to your house
just recently acre has introduced a new
hundred dollar a month prescription
to their five gram gold bar also check
this out you know there's a nationwide
ammo shortage well acres crafting a
solid gold 24 carat nine millimeter
bullet
that you can buy right now now you
cannot find anything like this on the
market i guess i should say
you shouldn't shoot the bullet one that
would be a very expensive round and
unless you're killing a werewolf there's
really no no purpose to that
uh but it's a very very cool product
visit getacregold.com
michael start investing in physical gold
today make sure that you go to this url
because acre is giving away a gold bar
to qualify for the giveaway
tweet or post why you should be the
recipient mentioned at get underscore
acre that's gideon.com
michael thank you aker gold for
supporting the show naomi wolf goes on
tucker's show
and says enough is enough with the
lockdowns
autocratic tyrants at the state and now
than the national level
are are creating a kind of merger of
corporate power and government power
which is really characteristic of
italian fascism in the 20s
and they're they're using that to engage
in kind of emergency orders
that that simply strip us of our rights
rights to property rights to assembly
rights to worship and all of the rights
that our constitution guarantees so
people are definitely horrified and
noticing i think people are
shocked and um and and divided as i
mentioned before
and the other thing that happened is you
said this has all been very sudden
um and when you look back you know march
of 2020
a lot of things started to move that
kind of locked into place a set of
policies
that are kind of 360 degree full-on
totalitarian policies
so i think a lot of us are kind of in
culture shock luckily or unluckily
i've been studying closing democracies
for 12 years so i recognized early on
you know once once i realized new york
state had emergency powers
i know from history that no one gives up
emergency powers willingly
right now i have a sort of
grudging respect for nomie wolfe and not
just because she went on tucker's show
and
said she doesn't like dr fauci or
something i've actually thought this for
a while because i disagree with most of
what naomi wolf thinks i think most
conservatives would
but the thing i always liked about her
is at least
she's following the arguments honestly
by
the lights that she's got so for
instance this quote got her into a lot
of trouble on the left
on the issue of abortion she's
pro-abortion but she also admits
that it's murder which is pretty pretty
ghastly stuff
but i actually have greater respect for
someone
who can say yeah i support abortion but
i'm not going to use mealy-mouthed words
like
reproductive rights or women's health or
you know anything else i'm going to deal
with the fact that yeah this is a
a grave moral issue and
i just think that women's convenience
needs to trump the life of the unborn
child she said
quote abortion should be legal it is
sometimes even necessary
uh don't agree with either of those
things obviously sometimes the mother
must be able to
to decide that the fetus in its full
humanity
must die
the people who got angry at her for that
quote were not conservatives they were
left-wingers who said stop being so
honest
don't tell them what we actually think
about this issue don't tell them the
reality of it but i think that she's
getting the reality of the lockdowns
quite right
it's just a simple law of politics
that politicians very rarely are willing
to give up
emergency powers you think of i don't
know cincinnatus george washington
a handful of examples throughout history
not too many
more and more what they do is they just
keep those emergency powers and add on
to them
and that's what we're seeing here dr
fauci the exalted one dr
fauci just came on television after
telling us yeah you're gonna have to
wear masks into 2022
you're going to have to until the virus
goes down below zero you're gonna have
to wear masks
now he's telling us that he's gonna get
maybe he's gonna give us a few of our
rights and liberties back
but uh not too many and there's just
there's certain things that we're not
gonna be able to do like for instance go
to restaurants
there will be things that you will not
be able to do
because the burden of virus in society
will be very high which it is right now
even though we're going way down on the
decline that dr olensky
showed you we are still at an
unacceptably high baseline
level with the seven day average being
quite high so there are things even if
you're vaccinated
that you're not going to be able to do
in society for example
indoor dining theaters places where
people congregate
that's because of the safety of society
you yourself what you can do
when you are together with another
person we are looking at that
and we're going to try and find out very
quickly what recommendations could be
made about what people can do
there are some things that you're just
not going to be
able to do says
who says dr fauci
some things that you're not going to be
able to do go indoor dining
going to movie theaters the theater
broadly
or going to places where people
congregate
so the things that you're not going to
be able to do
include everything everything that
people do
individuals i guess can stay home and
maybe read a book
as long as it's an approved book by the
way increasingly in our
in our censorship regime but
the things that people do you know
together you're just not going to be
able to do that
because of society a healthy society
would run this man out of the country on
a rail
that's what a healthiest and i'm not
talking about the health of avoiding the
the wuhan cough i'm saying a healthy
society that understands how to govern
itself
but we're not a healthy society so we
let
this little technocratic napoleon come
in
and and and destroy
our american way of life almost
single-handedly i mean
obviously politicians are in some ways
encouraging him to do it in other ways
are being rolled over by him
but this guy why does this guy get to do
it you know
hate to say i told you so i have been on
the anti-fouchy train
basically from the beginning at this
point and uh
there were a lot of conservatives who
said no we like fauci no it's okay you
know he's got good interests
now though basically every conservative
i think realizes
what the real situation is here even
megan mccain who you know is not
not the furthest right member of the
republican party megan mccain was on the
view though and she said oh boy i've had
enough of this guy
it's time to fire fauchi i i'm over dr
fauci i think we need to have more
people giving more opinions
and i i honestly quite frankly i think
the biden administration should
should remove him and put someone else
in place that maybe does understand
science or can talk to other
countries about how we can be more like
these places that are doing this
successfully
this is important i mean this is a
change because for people who are to the
right of genghis khan
such as myself we i think we had fauci's
number from the beginning we knew what
this was all about from the beginning
but people who were a little bit more in
the center people who were a little bit
more
you know in terms of the republican
party or the conservative movement who
are a little bit more on the left
for them now to be turning on fauci i
think shows the sea change
the problem is it may just be too late
the guy has got a lot of power we're now
in a sort of
new normal this has been going on for a
very long time so what do the science
and data show
well there's a very happy story to come
out of kovid lucia de klerk
who is the oldest resident of a new
jersey nursing home
just beat the coronavirus after testing
positive
on her 105th birthday
i'm very glad to hear that for ms de
klerk
i'm pleased that it sounds like a happy
105th birthday indeed
this two weeks after the oldest woman in
europe a 116 year old nun
beat coronavirus now we were told that
coronavirus is basically the most
dangerous
epidemic we've ever faced as a society
that's why we took the unprecedented
step to shut down the whole society
change everybody's behavior when uh
when the data started to contradict the
narrative the fear-mongering that we've
been told you know for instance younger
people
basically not at a very great risk from
the virus then we were told well it's
just older people if you're
older than 65 or really 75 or really 85
then
then you're truly at risk and yeah you
are at a higher risk
according to the evidence we've seen
when
105 year olds and 116 year olds
are beating the virus that we are told
is
going to kill just about anybody
certainly anybody who's a little bit up
in
age i think you have to start
questioning
some of the narrative around the virus i
think
i mean i love this these photos of like
105 year old being like what coronavirus
by the way you know what this woman her
tips for healthy living lucia de clerc
are prayer totally agree avoiding junk
food
may be debatable and eating nine
gin soaked raisins each morning my
girl a woman after my own heart what do
you think is in the leftist tears
tumbler
absolutely love that this reminds me of
of
the former oldest living world war ii
veteran who just
died a couple years ago in texas who
smoked 12 cigars a day
loved that guy his name escapes me at
the moment but great guy
it has been 345 days
since 15 days to slow the spread some of
us
called it at the beginning and we said
don't give them an inch
on this they're lying to you they one
don't know what they're talking about in
terms of the virus itself
which was born out again and again but
two they're lying to you this is not
just going to be 15 days this is going
to go on much longer
they're not going to let us return to
normal if we wear the masks actually the
masks are
probably going to serve as a symbol to
prolong these sorts of lockdowns
we're now coming up on a year of 15 days
to slow the spread and we're already
being promised
another year of it maybe another year
after that
how long before people wake up
you know one great way to wake up in the
morning listen to the bench bureau show
today he's going to be talking about
looking for systemic racism
in all the wrong places and tonight we
are going to be doing our backstage show
7 p.m eastern
we're going to be joined by all the
usual gang we're going to have stogies
we're going to have
booze it's going to be a lot of fun in
other news we've got a new show coming
out this friday featuring
mr ben shapiro there are a lot of
narratives going on around a lot of hot
topics it's hard to keep track of all
the newest non-traverses and
controversies of the left
which is why you're going to want to
tune into debunked to see ben exposed
leftist fallacies in 15 minutes or less
this show will be available exclusively
to daily wire members if you're not
already a member
very simple go to dailywire.com
subscribe use the code debunked
to get 25 off the reasons to join daily
wire are piling up by the day i'm being
crushed in all of the reasons
it is an avalanche of reasons go use
code debunked 25
off today we'll be right back with a lot
more
some people are being or are describing
this uh covid lockdown and the way it's
transforming society they're describing
it as the great
reset they're describing it and actually
some
prominent people you know i think the
members of the
royal family in the united kingdom have
described it this way prime ministers
and statesmen around the world
have described this opportunity to reset
the economy reset
society uh hopefully it won't be reset
along the lines of these crazy
technocrat power mad
losers in lab coats but there is a
sort of a reset happening in the sense
that
politics changes by the day
circumstances change and so politics
changes
and the old political consensus on the
left and on the right
is kind of cracking up that's why you're
seeing on the left
the rise of the woke people and on the
right you're seeing the rise of the
red-pilled people right those are the
two euphemisms that we're using
woke and red pilled they mean the same
thing right they mean sort of waking up
out of this dream state to see reality
what people are noticing
is the political reality is different
than what the major parties are telling
you it is
and so you're going to have to adjust
accordingly and
the entire trump candidacy i think was a
consequence of this
realizing that the old republican party
wasn't really serving its constituents
wasn't really speaking to the broader
gop base
so the gop is trying to reset now
i think the gop is pretty clearly much
more the party of workers and of the
working class and
blue-collar people than the democratic
party
uh ted cruz has described this as the
difference between the party of
pittsburgh and the party of paris you
know when you think of the democrats you
think
of either of these crazy rich kids on
college campuses talking about
intersectionality
or you think of john kerry another crazy
rich kid who's flying around on private
jets talking about how the sun monster
is going to kill us all
so you think of them and when you think
of the republican party you think of
those deplorable
irredeemable mega supporting
bitter clinging rubes in the middle of
the country
and so i think that that class class
divide and kind of
geographic divide has has actually taken
place
now how is that going to manifest in
policy the way you're seeing it manifest
is that the gop is beginning to break
away from
some of its uh what would you call it
free market
absolutism and i think that's actually a
good thing
you know free markets are great in their
place free markets are an instrument to
human flourishing but when you make an
idol out of free markets when you make a
when you make an idol out of money which
uh there's a very good book that tells
you not to do that
then things go haywire it reminds me of
what chesterton said
about vices and virtues he said heresy
is not when you produce
when you when you prefer vice to virtue
it's when you promote one virtue to the
exclusion of all of the others
so you know there's a role for the state
in
our society but when you make an idol
out of the state you get statism that's
bad
there's a role obviously for money
economic growth free markets there's a
huge role for that in society when you
make an idol out of that though when you
make that the only end of government
then you delve into a society that we're
in now which is
not functioning very well where families
are crumbling we're birth
birth rates are below replacement you
know a society that is quite literally
dying mitt romney has proposed an idea
which is sending direct payments to
families with children
this as a way to promote growing
families
marco rubio is trying to jump on this
bandwagon
rubio did it even less convincingly
though i think he said quote
sending 200 to 350 per month per child
to everyone
with no work requirement like mitt
romney wants to do
is welfare being pro-family means being
pro-work
our expanded child tax credit is a far
better approach
meaning you got the romney plan which is
just send money to families
and then that way they can raise their
kids and not have to limit their family
size
and rubio saying no you can't just send
the money we need them
all to be out working all the time but
if they make enough money we're going to
give them a tax credit
and this is kind of more the traditional
you know
mid 2000s 1990s kind of republican thing
i actually think being pro-family is
is bigger than both of those proposals
and this is going to be a really radical
one
and you're probably not going to hear
any republican lawmakers proposing this
but perhaps they should
being pro-family having having a society
that is pro-family
means having a society where only one
parent
needs to work and that one parent can
support the household
so that the other parent can stay home
and raise the family
i say this as a father now of a very
newborn cute little kid
i did not appreciate how difficult it is
to keep a baby alive
i did not for the mother not you know
for the father i what do i do i just
keep doing basically the same thing i do
i've been doing for years other than
maybe i'm sleeping a little bit less
but for mothers they basically never get
to sleep they're constantly
with the child if you have more than one
child that obviously adds a lot to the
workload
and then if you are at home doing that
sort of thing managing a home
economy is difficult and involves a lot
of work
when we had growing families in this
country because i'm not just speaking
the abstract i'm not just speaking in
some pie in the sky
solution out of the depths of my own
reason i'm just looking at how this used
to work
when we had a growing growing families
we had a growing population we had
a thriving society families were
able to be supported on the wages of
just one parent
that really began to change after the
second world war
obviously into the late 20th century to
the point that now you really can't it's
very difficult to support a family on
just one salary
in today's economy now you've got
romney who's kind of squishy but you
know at least he's looking at this
problem
you got rubio who i don't know rubio
seems to change his political colors
like by the day but now he's trying to
move into this pro family thing okay
who's going to go out there and make
this actual
real historical practical cultural
conservative claim
that if you really want to support
families then you need to be able
to support them with with one of the
parents
actually raising the family i i don't
think so but the politician who does do
that
the politician who's willing to say that
uncomfortable
but undeniable truth that politician i
think will have
some serious sway in the future
republican party a good example
of how the republican party needs to
change and how i think it is changing at
the moment
during the the terrible weather in texas
where the power went out because it
turns out windmills are not particularly
efficient
the texas power supplier gritty
warned some of its customers he said
look we have these
sort of strange plans that are very
deregulated they're very
very market focused so this can be
helpful during
good times but during a once in a
century kind of snowstorm
this is going to be really bad the plans
vary the price based on the supply of
energy
and when energy is more or less
completely cut off in texas
the price is going to go up through the
roof so people who normally would pay
out 100 bucks or something for your
energy
maybe a little less maybe a little bit
more some people
are getting bills for thousands and
thousands of dollars
karen cosby said that uh her energy
costs right now are five
thousand dollars to heat a 2 700 square
foot house
de'andre upshaw of tex of dallas said
the electric bill for his 900
square foot townhouse 900 square feet
was also 5 000 the spot prices
hit 9 000
per megawatt hour to put that into
comparison
nine dollars per kilowatt hour normally
that costs
about seven cents goes up to nine
thousand dollars per megawatt hour
sometimes it can go down as low as two
cents in ordinary times
so ted cruz senator from texas much
maligned senator from texas if you tune
in to cnn or any left-wing outlet these
days
tweeted out this is wrong no power
company should get a windfall because of
a natural disaster and texans
shouldn't get hammered by ridiculous
rate increases for last week's energy
debacle
state and local regulators should act
swiftly
to prevent this injustice a friend of
mine i saw this on twitter the other day
so rob sharma young conservative
writer so rob saw
this story about the energy prices going
up and he said you know it's only going
to be a matter of time
before some market obsessed sociopath
says that it is bad to give people
relief for their five thousand dollar
spot energy bill
just a few moments later you had these
kind of market obsessed
economics idolaters come out and say we
can't
you have to make deandre upshaw pay the
5 000
heating bill otherwise you'll disturb
our idol
of the market and that would be really
terrible i don't think any just society
believes that people in a once in a
century storm
should have to pay five thousand ten
thousand dollars
to heat their home or keep the lights on
when when the windmills stop turning
i'm not saying we throw out the free
market i'm not saying that we
ignore economic considerations but we
have to realize that
economics like so many other parts of
our society is ordered
towards something that there is a higher
good
in our political system which brings me
to
our old pal ron paul i want to preface
this segment in which i criticize ron
paul
by saying i generally like ron paul
i especially i really liked him in 2008
but ron paul
he's this confounding figure because
he's gotten something so much
more correct than the gop over his
career
in some ways the new republican party
has to move toward what ron paul is
saying
but in some ways he's gotten some things
totally wrong
he just totally misunderstands politics
and there was a clip that came out from
1988
on some rambunctious television show you
think our politics is crazy now this
show is like really
raucous this clip
shows both and it went viral yesterday
so take a listen to ron paul's
prescription for the country ask me why
we still finance the communists ask me
why seventy percent of the military
budget is spent overseas
ask me why the good airplanes are
overseas and the lousy airplanes are
not here in the the lousy airplanes were
in this air national guard
i would say clean out the state
department spend more money on our
national defense
have an anti-communist uh policy don't
sign these treaties with the soviet
don't extend loans to the soviet union
and not to fight these wars with the
funds we raised from the illegal drugs
so under the libertarian society no we
don't fight vietnam wars we don't fight
the korean wars
we fight wars to defend america
excuse me yes we get high we get high
more we get
high on the ideas of freedom we get high
because
freedom
love that answer yes we do get high on
freedom
well you're asking me if i'm high well
i'm high on life
so some things here that ron paul says
totally right when he says we've got to
clear out the state department
if we've learned nothing from the past
four years we know there's a ton of
corruption
in the state department in the deep
state you call the bureaucracy the
federal blob
so absolutely i think he's right on that
i think america did bungle a lot of its
foreign policy
ron paul is calling for a totally
isolationist foreign policy
that seems a little extreme for my
tastes but
broadly speaking i think he says a lot
of smart things then
then he goes a little bit too far a
little bit too
abstract he ignores the practical
wisdom of the american tradition
for the brilliant rationalist
abstractions plucked out of his own head
let me answer that just say no assume
the responsibility of yourself don't
assume that government makes your
decisions
it's a tyrannical approach to solving a
social medical problem
and we endorse the idea of voluntarism
and self-responsibility family friends
and churches to solve a problem
rather than saying some monolithic
government is going to make you take
care of yourself and be a better person
it's a preposterous notion it never
works
it never will the government can't make
you a better person it can't make you
follow good habits why don't they put
you on a diet you're a little overweight
and i think you'd be in better
healthcare
i'm tired of people like you using the
constitution
to do whatever you want to do i i
actually love that woman's
answer and i think here's where ron paul
loses me he's talking about
drug laws he's basically saying all
drugs need to be legal
and once all drugs are legal that's
going to be great first of all we're in
the midst of
the this horrible opioid crisis where
i i know people who have died from it i
suspect you might know people or you at
least know people who know people who
have died from this opioid
crisis what is your evidence that
legalizing all of these drugs
is going to be a good thing that
legalizing all these drugs is going to
help people to flourish or help people
to enjoy their freedom what what ron
paul is
confusing here is liberty and
licentiousness
he he thinks that when you get to pursue
your appetites however you want that's
what liberty is
that's that's not what liberty is we
talked about this yesterday liberty
according to lord acton long venerated
by
by libertarians liberty in the
conception of the founding fathers
is the ability to do what you ought to
do
it's the ability to do the right thing
it's not the freedom
to do whatever you want to pursue your
appetites do you think that a heroin
addict is free do you think a heroin
addict has liberty
no a heroin addict is a slave he has no
liberty at all he's squandered his
liberty he can't tame his passions he
can't tame his appetites
he can't master his higher faculties and
pursue liberty this is not some radical
notion
we have known this since the ancient
greeks we've known this at least since
old uncle aristotle
we've known this throughout the american
political tradition and
i by the way i think the republican
approach to yeah do whatever you want as
long as it doesn't affect me
we've already been trying that we've
tried that for decades and it hasn't
worked
we've lost the entire culture by doing
that so whatever what i'm not giving an
easy answer i'm saying
whatever the future republican party is
whatever the future of the conservative
movement is
it's going to have to be different than
that it's going to have to be different
than what is called
neo-conservatism you know sort of the
bush era stuff it's going to have to be
different
than the kind of radical abstractions of
ron paul which have
in many ways never first of all never
been tried anywhere because
they're not practical ideas they haven't
worked
where they have been tried we maybe need
to take a little bit from ron paul a
little bit from the libertarians a
little bit
from tradition traditional conservatives
obviously
and we need to look at what sort of
society we want to have
i don't i don't think there is a simple
answer to this question that's why
politicians are duking it out
right now now
speaking of volunteerism which i love
you know i
i like a lot of things that people like
ron paul and those libertarians i like
volunteerism i like subsidiarity i
obviously love federalism
but to say that the government has no
role
in these huge questions that that is to
cede
our political right that is to cede
our ability for self-government to the
left which is going to use it but look
we have been doing that we've been
conceding
our political rights for a very long
time and the left has been taking them
look at where it's gotten us not very
far but speaking of volunteerism
someone is voluntarily canceling himself
a beloved
voice actor harry shearer from the
simpsons which is apparently still
on air it's surprising to me too but it
is
the i think the simpsons is older than
me slight very
slightly older than me so harry shearer
has been voicing
uh the role of dr hibber for
years and years and we're going on like
30 years now
but he's no longer going to do that
because you see harry shearer is white
dr hibbert is black you probably didn't
know that harry shearer is white
because he's a voice actor and dr
hibbert is a cartoon
but we are now in the era that tells you
that you
cannot culturally appropriate
and so he's going to give up his 30-year
voice his voice job and he's going to
give it to
kevin michael richardson who i've never
heard who is a black
voice actor and now that's going to make
things better because white people
cannot
appropriate anyone else's culture but
also
white people need to be less white
remember
that's what robin d'angelo said in that
training that's associated with
coca-cola
all those diversity equity inclusions
they tell you you got to be
less white but also you can't
appropriate anybody else's culture
so uh what are you supposed to do
are you supposed to stay perfectly still
i don't know it seems kind of white to
me
you haven't your skin looks exactly the
same so you got to do better than that
what there's nothing you can do
it's a rigged game it's a rigged request
it's not not based in anything
actionable or anything true
which we're seeing more and more these
days this my favorite
non-traversing from this comes from dear
old yale the yale
law journal at yale law school
is being accused of racism
what we have heard if you've been paying
attention to these sort of silly campus
politics is that
black people are under-represented on
the yale law journal masthead
a journal editor gavin jackson just
resigned saying he felt used and
tokenized
in his position and so he's going to
resign
this racist organization racist
publication
so people took a look at the numbers
turns
out turns out you're going to be shocked
to hear this
not only are blacks and hispanics not
marginalized at the yale law journal
they are admitted to this law journal
at a higher rate than white people
the admissions rate for black students
to the yale law journal
is 61 percent much
much much higher than that of any other
ethnic group
the anti-racists wanted to show evidence
of racism and they did show evidence of
racism
racism against apparently white students
now i don't think that differing rates
of admittance
are in and of themselves evidence of
racial bigotry or discrimination they're
very very likely
maybe but but these guys certainly think
they do
by the logic of these race hustlers
at yale law school the yale law journal
is racist
very racist against white students
do you think this is now going to become
a national news story uh probably not
because when there is actual
institutional systemic racism
against white and asian students in the
form of say affirmative action policies
that is ignored that you won't even get
a hearing
remember those chinese students who were
i think
forget if it was chinese specifically or
if it was a group of asian students more
broadly
sued harvard for discrimination
sorry nope not going to hear that one
the department of justice under donald
trump was looking into racial
discrimination on the same grounds
at yale but whoops
sorry biden is now the president we're
not going to look into that anymore
this kind of radical racial policy it's
not just affecting our nation's most
prestigious
universities it's going down into
elementary schools christopher ruffa who
covers
these sorts of issues specifically
critical race theory at city journal is
doing great stuff
he just got a scoop that buffalo public
schools are now claiming quote all white
people
perpetuate systemic racism they are now
forcing kindergartners there according
to this report
to watch a video of dead black children
warning them about racist police and
state-sanctioned violence
he says that he's got the whistleblower
documents here
this is the sort of thing being this is
the narrative being foisted
on students now it doesn't just start
when you're
a law school student it starts when
you're a little kid and by the way this
does actually tie into the kind of ron
paul
vision of liberty and libertarianism or
whatever
we have we have to make sense of our
liberty we do that through liberal
education and this has been true for
millennia
liberal education exists to teach us to
tamp down our passions and our base
desires
and to pursue our our higher ordered
appetites and you know pursue our
our virtues and and practice the virtues
and make sense
of our own freedom this is why the left
always goes after the kids that's why
they go after education
broadly and they go after education
really hard and why they go after
younger and younger kids because
if you can get to a kid when he's five
years old you have a much greater
opportunity to shape his mind
this is why maybe some of you when you
were growing up your parents said hey
don't watch the simpsons or at least
don't watch this don't watch that you
can't watch that movie that's why
there's rating systems in movies
because we know that children absorb
much more than adults do the content
that is around them and it helps shape
the way that they think
it's why we're much more concerned about
keeping
kids away from obscene material than we
are about keeping adults away because
when you're an adult you're a little
more formed
it's going to have less of an effect on
you well the left
is now not just going after the adults
or even the teenagers they're all the
way going after the kids with this sort
of perverse
policies not just throwing the kids in
cages which joe biden's doing but but
things that are actually much
much more dangerous i'm michael gnosis
the michael knowles show
we'll just have to get to more tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
well show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show